a girl doing a review on eating ass
hi so uh this video
is my official review
of eating ass one second i think i need
music here because
she is she gonna put a soundtrack to her
talking about doo doo oh fix your nails
why do her nails look like she's been
digging through ass
this weekend recently i um
had the pleasure of eating ass she
called me
people have asked me vanessa
why and i said why not
and i said why not
hey this girl
makes a valid point she said why not
that's a ryder dabbit i'm not mad at her
go girl eat that ass and another they
have asked me
how was it and
i have given lots of that into this
question and i have decided that it
would be best that i just make a general
review
in my one experience of eating ass
um now
first of all i rate
the experience a 6.5 out of 10.
originally i ran out of six but i gave
it some fun
but i gave it some five and i think a
6.5 is more fitting
um i guess i'll lay out the pros and
cons
now the pros of eating ass
are the other person will enjoy it not
everybody will enjoy it but
a lot of people do another pro is that
it doesn't taste bad
most people think that it tastes bad or
they think it'll taste like poop but it
doesn't it tastes exactly like any
other body part that you would
lick for whatever reason it doesn't
taste like anything
it's not hard to do it's very easy to do
uh so those those are the pros um the
cons would be
i would say the biggest con is the smell
it doesn't smell that great
but um you could also ask the person to
like wash their ass real quick
before so the smell isn't
that bad i'm sorry you can wash your ass
as much as you want if you got a smelly
rectum it's a wrap like you unless she
going in
there with a colonoscopy i love this
girl
i go boo-boo
eat that ass and she made a review no
hey why did you talk about that [ __ ]
like it's a plain
five-star restaurant it's okay hold on
i'm
no i love yes girl
the smell isn't pleasant but the smell
is very bearable i would say
um another con
would be sometimes this person has not
shaved their ass
has not their ass
jesus christ
really won't appreciate the amount of
hair
that can potentially be in somebody's
i think that's it for the cons so
essentially
the pros way of the cons i mean
i was very upset after i ate ass
because of the amount of people who i've
heard say i don't eat ass
okay eating ass
is not bad um for all those who haven't
tried it i would say don't knock it till
you try it
for those who um
say they don't or they won't ever
i would say [ __ ] you because
you're a winner
[Music]
that escalated quickly we're already
overpopulated and we need to get rid of
the weak ones
that's you thank you for watching my
review yo
she went full school shooter mode at the
end no
but it's it's whatever you want
i ain't mad at her go ahead but
eat ass and make a review out of it
natural selection like evolution is like
eat ass or die [ __ ] hey all the things
all the well i don't know what her name
is go ahead baboo
[Music]
get your ass eat ass
eat ass yeah i'm not licking your ass no
more i don't like that [ __ ] it's nasty
so if you enjoyed that project check us
out on youtube since that's where we put
everything we do we don't try to put
everything on facebook mostly because
we don't get paid on facebook we're
trying to make money you know what i'm
saying we're trying to get
youtube money you know what i'm saying
so check us out over there we also have
an instagram page
uh twitter we don't have a twitter
snapchat i can't be bothered too much
but follow us on the social mediums
connect with us we like to talk to
everybody
so yeah